m
vieux de 150 ans le pont de la rivière
du mât qui relie bras panon à
saint-andré et salazie depuis pagne
antilles est en travaux depuis sept mois
environ 7000 usagers à emprunter cette
route chaque jour le département a donc
décidé de réparer la structure de
l'ouvragé musée par le temps un travail
précis et minutieux une usure plus
importante que prévu qui ont retardé la
fin des travaux
aujourd'hui malheureusement une mauvaise
surprise
l'état du pot qui était bien pire que ce
à quoi on s'attendait
il a fallu faire le bien
de réparation prévue entre ça prend
beaucoup de temps alors au démarrage on
a commencé à démolir la dalle des taux
qui était un des soucis d'équilibrage
des soucis connus à savoir cette dame
qui constituent deux épaisseurs de béton
de 7 cm et donc on avait 32 ceinture et
de charges de béton point mort sur sept
mois ce qui est très pénalisant
donc
le but de ce chantier 7 des manières
cette dalle que reprenait une dalle 15 5
et 9 d'épaisseur donc gagné 10,7 cm
d'épaisseur de béton en quoi mort ce qui
permet de soulager considérablement la
structure
malgré le travail acharné des ouvriers
sur ce chantier la réouverture du pont
de la rivière du mât n'a pas pu se faire
dans les délais prévus
toutefois à la fin des travaux les
usagers pourront emprunter un pro
flambant neuf est entièrement sécurisé